back in december of last year pc game
platform gog.com removed descent descent
two and two sent three mercenary from
their store citing changing hands and in
flux legal agreements allegedly this
referred to royalty payments that were
not being paid from rights holder
interplay to the original game creators
from karolac software Matt Tosh log and
Mike clueless in December the game
creators released a statement that read
we've talked to them about this numerous
times over the years and finally took
action this fall we served into play
official notice that they were in breach
of the contract and when they still
failed to pay we terminated the
agreement this means that interplay has
lost the right to sell to descent games
which is why they came down from God at
the time the two expressed hope that the
descent games could be restored to Gog
and that interplay would address the
issue today however Tosh login coolest
told kotaku the interplay still owes
them tens of thousands of dollars in
royalties from sales of the original
descent games stay tuned to GameSpot's
are all the latest on this story and
everything else that matters in gaming